[Music]
now that we've seen what a derivative
means and what it has to do with rates
of change our next step is to learn how
to actually compute these guys as in if
I give you some kind of function with an
explicit formula you'd want to be able
to find what the formula for its
derivative is maybe it's obvious but I
think it's worth stating explicitly why
this is an important thing to be able to
do why much of a calculus students time
ends up going towards grappling with
derivatives of abstract functions rather
than thinking about concrete rate of
change problems is because a lot of
real-world phenomena the sort of things
that we want to use calculus to analyze
are modeled using polynomials
trigonometric functions Exponential's
and other pure functions like that so if
you build up some fluency with the ideas
of rates of change for those kinds of
pure abstract functions it gives you a
language to more readily talk about the
rates at which things change in concrete
situations that you might be using
calculus to model but it is way too easy
for this process to feel like just
memorizing a list of rules and if that
happens if you get that feeling it's all
so easy to lose sight of the fact that
derivatives are fundamentally about just
looking at tiny changes to some quantity
and how that relates to a resulting tiny
change in another quantity so in this
video and in the next one my aim is to
show you how you can think about a few
of these rules intuitively and
geometrically and I really want to
encourage you to never forget that tiny
nudges are at the heart of derivatives
let's start with a simple function like
f of x equals x squared what if I asked
you it's derivative that is if you were
to look at some value X like x equals 2
and compare it to a value slightly
bigger just DX bigger what's the
corresponding change in the value of the
function DF and in particular what's DF
divided by DX the rate at which this
function is changing per unit change in
X as a first step for intuition we know
that you can think of this ratio DF DX
as the slope of a tangent line to the
graph of x squared and from that you can
see that the slope generally increases
as x increases at 0 the tangent line is
flat in the slope is 0 at x equals 1
that's something a bit steeper
at x equals two it's steeper still but
looking at graphs isn't generally the
best way to understand the precise
formula for a derivative for that it's
best to take a more literal look at what
x-squared actually means and in this
case let's go ahead and picture a square
whose side length is X if you increase X
by some tiny nudge some little DX
what's the resulting change in the area
of that square that slight change in
area is what DF means in this context
it's the tiny increase to the value of f
of X equals x squared caused by
increasing X by that tiny nudge DX now
you can see that there's three new bits
of area in this diagram two thin
rectangles and a miniscule square the
two thin rectangles each have side
lengths of X and DX so they account for
two times x times DX units of new area
for example let's say X was 3 and DX was
0.01 then that new area from these two
thin rectangles would be 2 times 3 times
0.01 which is 0.06 about 6 times the
size of DX that little square there has
an area of DX squared but you should
think of that as being really tiny
negligibly tiny for example if DX was
0.01 that would be only 0.0001 and keep
in mind I'm drawing DX with a fair bit
of width here just so we can actually
see it but always remember in principle
DX should be thought of as a truly tiny
amount and for those truly tiny amounts
a good rule of thumb is that you can
ignore anything that includes a DX
raised to a power greater than 1 that is
a tiny change squared is a negligible
change what this leaves us with is that
DF is just some multiple of DX and that
multiple 2x which you could also write
as DF divided by DX is the derivative of
x squared for example if you were
starting at x equals 3 then as you
slightly increase X the rate of change
in the area per unit change in length
added DX squared over DX would be 2
times 3 or 6 and if instead you were
starting at x equals 5
the rate of change would be ten units of
area per unit change in X
let's go ahead and try a different
simple function f of x equals x cubed
this is going to be the geometric view
of the stuff that I went through
algebraically in the last video what's
nice here is that we can think of X
cubed as the volume of an actual cube
whose side lengths are X and when you
increase X by a tiny nudge a tiny DX the
resulting increase in volume is what I
have here in yellow that represents all
the volume in a cube with side lengths x
plus DX that's not already in the
original cube the one with side length X
it's nice to think of this move all Youm
as broken up into multiple components
but almost all of it comes from these
three square faces or set a little more
precisely as DX approaches zero
those three squares comprise a portion
closer and closer to 100% of that new
yellow volume each of those thin squares
has a volume of x squared times DX the
area of the face times that little
thickness DX so in total this gives us
three x squared DX of volume change and
to be sure there are other slivers of
volume here along the edges and that
tiny one in the corner but all of that
volume is going to be proportional to DX
squared
or DX cubed so we can safely ignore them
again this is ultimately because they're
going to be divided by DX and if there's
still any DX remaining then those terms
aren't going to survive the process of
letting DX approach 0 what this means is
that the derivative of X cubed the rate
at which X cubed changes per unit change
of X is 3 times x squared
what that means in terms of graphical
intuition is that the slope of the graph
of x cubed at every single point X is
exactly three x squared and reasoning
about that slope it should make sense
that this derivative is high on the left
and then zero at the origin and then
high again as you move to the right but
just thinking in terms of the graph
would never have landed us on the
precise quantity 3 x squared for that we
had to take a much more direct look at
what x cubed actually means now in
practice you wouldn't necessarily think
of the square every time you're taking
the derivative of x squared nor would
you necessarily think of this cube
whenever you're taking the derivative of
x cubed both of them fall under a pretty
recognizable pattern for polynomial
terms the derivative of X to the fourth
turns out to be 4x cubed the derivative
of X to the fifth is 5x to the fourth
and so on abstractly you'd write this as
the derivative of X to the N for any
power N is n times X to the N minus 1
this right here is what's known in the
business as the power rule in practice
we all quickly just get jaded and think
about this symbolically as the exponent
hopping down in front leaving behind one
less than itself
rarely pausing to think about the
geometric delights that underlie these
derivatives that's the kind of thing
that happens when these tend to fall in
the middle of much longer computations
but rather than tracking it all off to
symbolic patterns let's just take a
moment and think about why this works
for powers beyond just 2 and 3 when you
nudge that input X increasing it
slightly to X plus DX working out the
exact value of that nudged output would
involve multiplying together these n
separate X plus DX terms the full
expansion would be really complicated
but part of the point of derivatives is
that most of that complication can be
ignored the first term in your expansion
is X to the N this is analogous to the
area of the original square or the
volume of the original cube from our
previous examples
for the next terms in the expansion you
can choose mostly X's with a single DX
since there are n
radicals from which you could have
chosen that single DX this gives us n
separate terms all of which include n
minus one X's times a DX giving a value
of X to the power n minus one times DX
this is analogous to how the majority of
the new area in the square came from
those two bars each with area x times DX
or how the bulk of the new volume in the
cube came from those three thin squares
each of which had a volume of x squared
times DX
there will be many other terms of this
expansion but all of them are just going
to be some multiple of DX squared so we
can safely ignore them and what that
means is that all but a negligible
portion of the increase in the output
comes from n copies of this X to the n
minus 1 times DX that's what it means
for the derivative of X to the n to be n
times X to the n minus 1 and even though
like I said in practice you'll find
yourself performing this derivative
quickly and symbolically imagining the
exponent hopping down to the front every
now and then it's nice to just step back
and remember why these rules work not
just because it's pretty and not just
because it helps remind us that math
actually makes sense and isn't just a
pile of formulas to memorize but because
it flexes that very important muscle of
thinking about derivatives in terms of
tiny nudges
as another example think of the function
f of X equals 1 divided by X now on the
one hand you could just blindly try
applying the power rule since 1 divided
by X is the same as writing X to the
negative 1 that would involve letting
the negative 1 hop down in front
leaving behind 1 less than itself which
is negative 2 but let's have some fun
and see if we can reason about this
geometrically rather than just plugging
it through some formula the value 1 over
X is asking what number multiplied by x
equals 1 so here's how I'd like to
visualize it imagine a little
rectangular puddle of water sitting in
two dimensions whose area is 1 and let's
say that its width is X which means that
the height has to be 1 over X since the
total area of it is 1 so if X was
stretched out to 2 then that height is
forced down to 1/2 and if you increased
X up to 3 then the other side has to be
squished down to 1/3 this is a nice way
to think about the graph of 1 over X by
the way if you think of this with X of
the puddle as being in the XY plane then
that corresponding output 1 divided by X
the height of the graph above that point
is whatever the height of your puddle
has to be to maintain an area of 1 so
with this visual in mind for the
derivative
imagine nudging up that value of x by
some tiny amount some tiny DX how must
the height of this rectangle change so
that the area of the puddle remains
constant at 1 that is increasing the
width by DX add some new area to the
right here so the puddle has to decrease
in height by some D 1 over X so that the
area lost off of that top cancels out
the area gained you should think of that
D 1 over X as being a negative amount by
the way since it's decreasing the height
of the rectangle and you know what I'm
going to leave the last few steps here
for you for you to pause and ponder and
work out an ultimate expression and once
you reason out what D of 1 over X / DX
should be I want you to compare it to
what you would have gotten if you had
just blindly applied the power rule
purely symbolically
to
X to the negative one and while I'm
encouraging a deposit ponder here's
another fun challenge if you're feeling
up to it see if you can reason through
what the derivative of the square root
of x should be
to finish things off I want to tackle
one more type of function trigonometric
functions and in particular let's focus
on the sine function so for this section
I'm going to assume that you're already
familiar with how to think about trig
functions using the unit circle the
circle with the radius one centered at
the origin
for a given value of theta like say zero
point eight you imagine yourself walking
around the circle starting from the
rightmost point until you've traversed
that distance of zero point eight in arc
length this is the same thing as saying
that the angle right here is exactly
theta radians
since the circle has a radius of one
then what sine of theta means is the
height of that point above the x-axis
and as your theta value increases and
you walk around the circle your height
Bob's up and down between negative one
and one so when you graph sine of theta
versus theta you get this wave pattern
the quintessential wave pattern
and just from looking at this graph we
can start to get a feel for the shape of
the derivative of the sine the slope at
zero is something positive since sine of
theta is increasing there and as we move
to the right and sine of theta
approaches its peak that slope goes down
to zero then the slope is negative for a
little while while the sine is
decreasing before coming back up to zero
as the sine graph levels out and as you
continue thinking this through and
drawing it out if you're familiar with
the graph of trig functions you might
guess that this derivative graph should
be exactly cosine of theta since all the
peaks and valleys line up perfectly with
where the peaks and valleys for the
cosine function should be and spoiler
alert the derivative is in fact the
cosine of theta but aren't you a little
curious about why it's precisely cosine
of theta I mean you could have all sorts
of functions with peaks and valleys at
the same points that have roughly the
same shape but who knows maybe the
derivative of sine could have turned out
to be some entirely new type of function
that just happens to have a similar
shape well just like the previous
examples a more exact understanding of
the derivative requires looking at what
the function actually represents rather
than looking at the graph of the
function so think back to that walk
around the unit circle having traversed
an arc with length theta and thinking
about sine of theta as the height of
that point
now zoom in to that point on the circle
and consider a slight nudge of D theta
along their circumference a tiny step in
your walk around the unit circle how
much does that tiny step change the sign
of theta how much does this increase D
theta of arc length increase the height
above the x-axis
well zoomed in close enough the circle
basically looks like a straight line in
this neighborhood so let's go ahead and
think of this right triangle where the
hypotenuse of that right triangle
represents the nudge D theta along the
circumference and that left side here
represents the change in height the
resulting D sine of theta now this tiny
triangle is actually similar to this
larger triangle here with the defining
angle theta and whose hypotenuse is the
radius of the circle with length one
specifically this little angle right
here is precisely equal to theta radians
now think about what the derivative of
sine is supposed to mean it's the ratio
between that D sine of theta the tiny
change to the height divided by D theta
the tiny change to the input of the
function and from the picture we can see
that that's the ratio between the length
of the side adjacent to the angle theta
divided by the hypotenuse well let's see
adjacent divided by hypotenuse that's
exactly what the cosine of theta means
that's the definition of the cosine
so this gives us two different really
nice ways of thinking about how the
derivative of sine is cosine one of them
is looking at the graph and getting a
loose feel for the shape of things based
on thinking about the slope of the sine
graph at every single point and the
other is a more precise line of
reasoning looking at the unit circle
itself for those of you that like to
pause and ponder see if you can try a
similar line of reasoning to find what
the derivative of the cosine of theta
should be in the next video I'll talk
about how you can take derivatives of
functions who combine simple functions
like these ones either as sums or
products or function compositions things
like that and similar to this video the
goal is going to be to understand each
one geometrically in a way that makes it
intuitively reasonable and somewhat more
memorable as you know by now there are
many people to thank for this series and
one group I'd like to call out
specifically is brilliant org I think
anyone watching this video would like
brilliant a lot because they offer a
problem solving website that teaches you
to think like a mathematician videos and
books can offer intuitions and
explanations but math is not a spectator
sport the only way to actually solidify
those intuitions is with your own
explorations and problem solving
brilliant offers really well curated
sequences of guided questions and
speaking as someone who's worked on
creating those kinds of sequences before
I can tell you a lot of thoughtful hard
work has gone into making these as good
as they are and the subscription they
offer to get the full suite of problems
is a really good deal if you go to
brilliant org slash three b-1b or more
simply just follow the links on the
screen or in the video description that
lets them know that you came from here
you can supplement this series with
their calculus done right sequence and I
would also recommend looking at their
probability and complex algebra
sequences
[Music]
you
you